et pour en parler nous sommes avec tak
lobby ton dont un bernard présidente de
l'association france-dépression jacques
milliard mer les républicains de maisons
laffitte et françois roudier
porte-parole du comité des constructeurs
français d'automobiles bonsoir à tous
les trois merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on parle
beaucoup on vient d'entendre dans ce
reportage aussi de la détresse des
petits commerçants mais il ya évidemment
d'autres pans entiers de l'industrie qui
sont en train d'être mis à dure épreuve
le tourisme notamment la restauration on
l'a vu l'aéronautique et françois
roudier les chiffres de l'automobile qui
sont tombés aujourd'hui le confinement a
été décidément fatale pour les
constructeurs les chiffres sont très
mauvais françois roudier
oui les chiffres sont très mauvais parce
que il faut comprendre que notre
industrie travaille de concert avec le
commerce on va pas produire des voitures
ils n'ont pas entendu ni réparer donc en
fait on est vraiment dans le cas typique
où le confinement nous a frappés lors du
premier confinement est maintenant une
double x puisque de toute façon nous
avons pu livrer des voitures à des
clients qu'ils ont commandés mais on
peut pas maintenant faire le commerce de
ces voitures pour pouvoir relancer les
livraisons
donc on commence à avoir un véritable
problème au début du mois on était à peu
près sur un chiffre qui était positif dû
progressivement tout tombe
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
trou du premier confinement a
complètement détruit notre industrie
vous êtes maintenant en gros a quasiment
entre -25 et -30 % de ventes en moins en
france mais aussi comme on l'a annoncé
ce matin dans l'europe entière
c'est une année c'est françois roudier
qui va pouvoir se relever de cet épisode
très difficile alors c'est complexe à
dire parce que notre industrie est là
une ramification très profonde
alors bien sûr on voit les grands
industriels les français les renault et
psa mais lorsque vous descendez dans
toute la chaîne des petits fournisseurs
c'est là où on risque d'avoir de très
gros
problème avec des fournisseurs qui n'ont
plus de trésorerie et qui peuvent se
mettre en cessation de paiement est
fermée alors je me trompe peut-être des
grosses fermetures d'usinés des petits
paquets de 2 200 de 50 personnes
est ce que vous avez dans l'industrie
vous aurez la même chose dans le
commerce des concessions automobiles qui
va nous avons pu faire face à leurs
charges
ils seront forcés d'arrêter justement
une trentaine de présidents
d'organisations confessionnelles ont
adressé un cri d'alarmé au premier
ministre jean castex
aujourd'hui en plus à une lettre commune
dans lequel ils réclament la réouverture
des commerces le 24 novembre il y a
clairement l'urgence et centre-ville
summer jacquerie amiard écouter les
centres-villes où il y à des commerces
de proximité alimentaires continuent de
vivre et c'est le cas à maisons laffitte
et je le constate et également dans
d'autres villes
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est que la
liste des commerces essentiel a été
arrêtée d'une manière totalement
arbitraire sans définition véritablement
de ce qu'est un commerce est essentielle
et on n'a pas du tout compris
personne n'a compris qui pourrait avoir
par exemple sur un cordonnier quelque
chose qui est non essentiels donc on
voit bien aujourd'hui que il y a eu une
sorte d'habitude arbitraire qui il ya eu
rupture d'égalité que ça c'est fait
parce qu'ils l'ont adoubée une liste
pondus par des technocrates un manque de
connaissance des proximités et j'en veux
d'état blement gouvernement parce que
moi j'ai pris un arrêté pour permettre
aux commerces non essentiels dit non
essentiels de rouvrir
j'ai constaté que bien évidemment il a
été suspendu par le tribunal
administratif
mais on voit bien que ça a été fait
d'une manière technocratique et ce n'est
pas acceptable
ce n'est pas acceptable ça monte un déni
de réalité
j'ajoute toute chose c'est que dans les
centre ville on nous a demandé de
manière simple éternelle qu'il fallait
muscler les centres-villes qu'il ne
fallait plus que ce soit des grandes
surfaces à l'extérieur des villes et
qu'il fallait animer les centres-villes
et pour cela on a mis en place des
politiques publiques qui coûtent parfois
assez cher avec les banques des
territoires etc
donc on a eu affaire à des prises de
position du gouvernement non réfléchie
et quand j'entends repectivement notre
ami parler de l'industrie il est clair
aujourd'hui que l'industrie il faut la
choyer
il faut lui permettre de deux tournées
15 et on voit très bien qu'en allemagne
c'est l'industrie beaucoup plus que les
services qui font vivre l'économie et
c'est cette industrie là que l'on doit
comporter et que l'on doit on doit lui
permettre de tourner et je ne suis pas
certain que le gouvernement en est pris
conscience même si on sait pas
pertinemment que il prend des mesures
sanitaires et je sais que dans les
entreprises
ils sont capables de le faire en tout
cas l'exécutif et son pression à le chef
de l'état va s'exprimer la semaine
prochaine tous clairement va le pouvoir
reprendre leurs activités
on a évoqué une possible réouverture de
ce constat la semaine prochaine et qui
ne semble pas si acte et ont écouté les
précisions du porte parole du
gouvernement
il y à ce nouveau palier autour du 1er
décembre qui fait l'objet de travaux
actuellement et un engagement du premier
ministre qui a été pris à ce que si la
situation sanitaire continue à
s'améliorer dans les proportions que
nous avons connues ces derniers jours
mais je rappelle que la situation reste
grave en france
si cette tendance se confirme et si l'un
protocole sanitaire est adoptée en
concertation avec les commerçants alors
cela pourra être envisagée c'est ce qu'a
dit le premier ministre sur ce point il
n'y a pas de décision qui a été prise à
ce stade
il ya des discussions par ailleurs qui
se poursuivre sous l'égide de bruno le
maire et de alain griset avec les
commerçants et d'ailleurs les échanges
que nous avons eus ce matin nous ont
permis de faire un point sur l'ensemble
des concertations qui sont menées
actuellement puisqu'elles sont
nombreuses on n'avait pas de décision
prise à ce stade c'est c'est bien le
problème un nouveau protocole sanitaire
manifestement pas vraiment clair ça veut
dire que le premier protocole le ne vaut
rien dans une certaine mesure françois
roudier comment vous percevez les choses
mais nous on les perçoit assez mal parce
que vous savez déjà dans l'industrie
automobile et même jour dans toute
l'industrie
les personnels sont habitués à respecter
des procédures parce que l'industrie ça
peut être dangereux peut se couper on
peut avoir des accidents donc le respect
des procédures
que ce soit dans l'industrie ou dans le
commerce automobile dans les concessions
dans les ateliers de réparation
c'est la vie tous les jours donc si vous
dites au personnel de suivre les
consignes ils le font et puis regardez
les concessions automobiles
on parle pas d'une petite boutique de
quatre mètres carrés une concession
automobile c'est toujours gants et vous
avez de la place pour recevoir les gens
donc on peut très bien avoir des
systèmes où on n'est pas entassés les
uns sur les autres
nous le vrai problème que nous avons
c'est que après avoir livré sait très
bien qu'on appelle le click and collect
enfin après avoir livré maintenant vous
avez des clients qui vont pas de
dépenser 15 mille 25000 euros comme ça
en cliquant sur leur ordinateur ils
veulent essayer la voiture
ils veulent pouvoir discuter avec le
vendeur et là dessus on ne sait pas
comment faire sans avoir le contact
physique
vous avez des contrôles dans vos
concessions parce que voilà on m'a
souvent rapporté que ce soit les agents
immobiliers dans les concessions
automobiles qu il y avait peut-être un
petit peu deux poids deux mesures
beaucoup de contrôle alors qu'il ya des
dérogations dans certaines villes pour
plusieurs commerces là on se fait passer
pour des faux clients et derrière c'est
la sanction immédiate et des miliers
d'euros d'amendés de la part des
autorités
bah écoutez je vous dirais oui oui parce
que c'est quand même assez lamentable on
a une profession qui est en souffrance
terrible
vous avez des gens qui peuvent perdre
leur affaire des affaires familiales
dans l'est dans l'automobile vous avez
des salariés qui sont sous une pression
absolument terrible d'abord ils ont leur
pression pour eux mêmes pour leurs
familles et en plus ils ont la pression
de leur boulot leur boulot qui est pour
eux essentielles vous savez que dans
l'automobile
c'est une véritable passion qu'on va
rentrer dans une concession automobile
c'est rare que vous trouvez pas un
vendeur passionnés qui va vous montrer
comment la voiture fonctionne et même
des voitures anciennes qui vous
rappellent l'identité de la marque et
tous ces gens là sont totalement frustré
alors si on va les flics et pour voir
que si la réparation essaye de dire à un
client mais vous pourrez peut-être
acheter mes cliques aimé regarder la
voiture non c'est lamentable je pense
que là il ya quand même un abus des
services de l'état qui est très très
néfaste à l'esprit d'entreprise
en tout cas tout cela crée beaucoup de
souffrance psychologique on en parle
peut-être un petit peu moins mais c'est
l'envers du décor ce deuxième
confinement qui est en plus de l'hiver
les étraves soit dans la population
écoute et jérôme sabbagh le directeur de
la santé à ce propos santé publique
france révèle aujourd'hui que la santé
mentale des français s'est de nouveau
dégradée entre fin septembre et début
novembre
la crise sanitaire ducobu 19 a révélé la
vulnérabilité psychique de nombreux
français on observe ainsi une
augmentation importante des états
dépressifs
le nombre de personnes concernées a en
effet doublé entre fin septembre et
début novembre
cette hausse est observée dans
l'ensemble de la population mais s'avère
encore plus marquée chez des personnes
en situation financière très difficile
les personnes ayant des antécédents de
troubles psychologiques
les inactifs et les jeunes et je me
tourne vers vous au claudie ton nom
bernard un président de l'association
france dépression c'est ce que vous
constatez également avec votre
association
oui bonjour donc effectivement on se
rend compte que ça touche surtout les
personnes les plus défavorisées et ils
vont encore plus s'enfoncer les comme si
nous renier aussi des familles les
familles dans des petits appartements où
les parents ont perdu leur emploi ou un
emploi il ya cette peur cette peur de
l'avenir cette part de plus qu plus
pouvoir manger même donc on a beaucoup
d'appels téléphoniques de d'être
et en plus on n'a plus la possibilité
non plus d'avoir da par le contact
téléphonique
on n'a plus la possibilité de rencontrer
les personnes
donc on n'a plus d'activités de groupes
de parole qui nous permettait d'échanger
vraiment avec les personnes nous donc ça
ça devient dramatique donc nous à notre
niveau on a mis en place un numéro de
téléphone que quand même donné c'est le
07 84 96 88 28 avec des écoutants parce
que souvent aussi d'isolement sacré
beaucoup d'isolement les personnes
seules qui ne voient plus d'autres
personnes mises allemand est encore bien
plus important en ce moment sacré
vraiment un gros problème si jacques
myard c'est sont également les remontées
de vos administrés ce moral en baisse on
a vu le long d'anxiolytiques i qui
augmentait considérablement ses
dépressions on l'a dit on l'a entendu de
la bouche de jérôme salomon c'est
extrêmement inquiétant vous le ressentez
sur vos terres que nous ressentons c'est
le ras-le-bol ça c'est évident et c'est
surtout aussi malheureusement face aux
décisions du gouvernement
une certaine incompréhension je ne sais
pas si vous avez vu cet après midi ou ce
soir sur des chaînes de télévision qu' à
l'évidence la la pandémie est en train
de tomber et que ça a commencé avant
même avant même leur confinement et donc
ça ça risque d'être mortel et parce que
ça démontre que le gouvernement navigue
à vue
alors ça peut se comprendre navigue à
vue c'est jamais évident de prédire
l'avenir mais ce qui est certain c'est
ça qui mine qui minent le moral des
français
c'est un l'incompréhension des mesures
du gouvernement de l'absence de sortie
du confinement de manière rationnelle
intelligente et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
nous avons mis en place et que nous
mettons actuellement en place dans notre
ville une sorte de brigade citoyenne
pour aller à la rencontre des personnes
isolées
c'est très important avec des
permanences téléphoniques
c'est très important de le faire parce
que c'est je crois la où il va y avoir
de plus de problème je vais vous dire
franchement je suis convaincu que
l'industrie repartira il va y avoir une
mauvaise phase
il rassemble des faillites d'entreprises
mais malheureusement on l'a vu encore
lorsque un certain nombre de personnes
sont à bout et arrive à commettre l'acte
ye dont on ne revient pas et qui ceux
qui se suicident ça c'est tellement
grave et je pense que c'est sur ce point
qu'il faut agir et nous les maires on
est à l'écouté bien évidemment de nos
concitoyens et je dirais je dirai au
gouvernement il est normal que vous
mettiez en garde les français mais ne
les ont merdé pas ne les emmerder pas
avec des contrôles permanents
1 il ya un moment ras-le-bol et attaque
vous faire très attention parce que on
vit est-ce que d'avoir non seulement des
faillites individuelles c'est à dire des
gens qui me pompe peuvent se suicider
mais on risque surtout aussi d'avoir une
révolte complète
déjà que ce gouvernement a une intrigue
ibilité féroce il n'a plus aucune
crédibilité mais si ça continue il
risque d'avoir un rejet parfois violents
donc j'en ai parlé par exemple avec le
commissaire de police
ils font attention hein il rappelle les
règles mais on va pas aller emmerder les
français par des amendes en permanence
ça n'a pas de sens et c'est dangereux on
reviendra vers vous et françois roudier
pour faire vous fait réagir aux propos
de jacques milliard mais justement
jacques myard qui a également évoqué
cette question est difficile du suicide
on a eu l'exemple en belgique
malheureusement on l'a appris qu'une
commerçante de 24 ans avait mis fin à
ses jours parce qu'elle venait
ouvrir son petit commerce et voilà est
clairement les raisons sont évoquées que
cette faillite précoce a entraîné son
suicide justement claudie tondant
bernard vous le craignez vous dans votre
association ce type de situations à
l'afflux des suicides en france
notamment
ben oui oui hein il ya quand même en
temps normal au moins déjà 9000 suicide
en france donc là je pense que ça va
être augmenté et puis le le mal être
aussi des personnes c'est de pas pouvoir
se projeter dans l'avenir
ils nous disent on peut pas faire de
projets donc on est mal on est mal voilà
on voudrait surtout aussi leur dire de
ne pas écouter les informations en
boucle parce que certaines personnes qui
sont devant leur télévision
toute la journée en train d'écouter des
informations qui souvent sont
contradictoires
donc qui vraiment démolissent le moral
des gens là c'est catastrophique oui
françois roudier peu de temps dont
bernard amis voilà le doigt sur quelque
chose d'important le manque de
perspectives et surtout de planification
dans votre industrie également on
imagine que c'est extrêmement important
de pouvoir planifier quelques mois à
l'avancé ce que vous naviguez
complètement a vu dans ce domaine où
vous avez quand même des pistes de la
part du gouvernement
alors on a eu un bon dialogue avec le
gouvernement sur les mesures sociales
sur des aides au maintien des aides tous
les véhicules électriques
et là-dessus il n'y a pas vraiment de
soucis et je crois que le discours le
dialogue est assez bon avec le
gouvernement sur ces sujets là bon on
regrette quand même quelques mesures
pseudo écologistes et qui sont plus du
quart bashing que de la réalité et de
préservation de l'environnement
mais le problème actuellement c'est
l'arrêt de la machine vous savez c'est
ce que je dis en fait l'automobile c'est
un tuyau d'un côté vous avez
et la production et au bon vous avez la
vente si vous fermez un coin du tuyau on
est bloqué donc là il faut absolument
réouvrir tout ça parce que les
conséquences sociales commencent on a vu
par exemple que nos constructeurs ont
arrêté des équipes de nuit avec des
intérimaires qui avaient été
sélectionnés et qui sont partis donc on
voit que tous tous ces petits problèmes
s'accumulent et se sont pas des masses
énormes qui vont être touchés en
salariés mais petit petit problème par
petits problèmes vous allez avoir 100
salariés 500 écoutes illicites revient
de personnes travaillent dans l'économe
dans l'oeil dans l'automobile a rien
qu'en france
alors quand vous prenez le l'industrie
et les services
on est à plus d'un million un million
sept cent mille personnes
et lorsque vous rajouter tout ce qui est
service transport dans les routiers en
particulier on arrive quasiment 1 9% de
la population active qui a un travail
qui est lié à l'automobile mais de
l'assureur qui va faire travailler sur
l'automobile il est lié à ce qui se
passe automobile actuellement l'assureur
qui assure sur l'automobile il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de livraisons donc il ne
fait rien vous voyez c'est tous toute
cette chaîne qui va être difficile à
redémarrer et il faut absolument que les
pouvoirs publics prennent conscience que
le respect des conditions sanitaires se
fait bien chez nous jacques myard
qu'est ce que vous attendez du président
de la république avait la semaine
prochaine vous savez je veux dire une
chose
il devrait moins parler parce que à
force de parler on se dit qu'est ce qui
va redire on a vu un certain nombre de
conférences de presse notamment du
premier ministre après rodez dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu dire
donc c'est très simple il faut avoir des
indicateurs simples à l'évidence
aujourd'hui il semble je dis bien il
semble qu'ils ont un ralentissement du
virus il le gouvernement doit obtenir
compte et je crois que le président de
la république ne doit pas s'exprimer
toutes les semaines tous les quinze
jours comme il le fait en revanche il
est évident qu'on sait ce qui va se
passer sur le plan je dirais politique
strictement je suis convaincu que les
commerces non essentiels vont sans doute
trop
rires si ce n'est à la fin du mois du
moins en début décembre
je suis également convaincu qu'on va
lever vers peut-être le 15 ou le 20
décembre
le confinement tel qu'on le pratique en
ayant un certain nombre de restrictions
et il est récent l'avait également qu
après les fêtes on revienne à un
confinement
parce que cette épidémie vous remontez
balmoral jacques myard vous ne montez
pas le moral mais non mais il faut
regarder les choses telles qu'elles sont
c'est pas la peine quand on a vu à tout
à l'heure le porte parole du
gouvernement a dit on à une adaptation
c'est un sac il faut s'en tenir
mais je dirais il s'exprime trop souvent
c'est que c'est dans la durée que ça va
se passer
on sait très bien que toutes les
épidémies ont une durée de deux ans
c'est ce qui s'est passé à la grippe
espagnole qui a été tragiquement là on a
peut-être un vaccin jacques myard tout
de même on nous promet un vaccin
on nous promet vaccin efficace et
attendez attendez moi alors là je vous
dire je suis comme ça mathieu 1
on va regarder ce qui se passe j'espère
que ça va fonctionner j'espère qu'on en
aura assez mais pour l'instant
effectivement c'est le sait la lumière
au bout du tunnel
mais est ce que c'est un train qui vient
en face je le sais pas encore bon donc
il faut sur ce point précis garder
raison
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'on peut
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
dans le respect des règles sanitaires
qui permettent à nos concitoyens de
respirer un peu et de ne pas être
considérés comme des enfants celle ci
merci en tout cas tous les trois un
merci jacques myard merci françois
roudier
merci également à claudie ton dont
bernard d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france merci